en el vídeo pasado estábamos intentando
determinar si hay una diferencia
significativa entre la proporción de
hombres y la proporción de mujeres que
votan por cierto candidato lo que
habíamos hecho es entrevistar a mil
hombres a mil mujeres y obtuvimos los
siguientes resultados obtuvimos una
proporción muestral para los hombres de
0.6 42 y para las mujeres de punto 5 91
nuestra meta era obtener un intervalo de
confianza del 95% ahora simplemente
basados en nuestra muestra déjame
escribirlo por aquí abajo o escribir la
diferencia la proporción muestral no
sabes que déjame hacerlo con otro color
con un color más neutral
entonces la proporción muestral de los
hombres menos la proporción muestral de
las mujeres es igual a ya que hay que
hacer la resta punto 6 42 menos puntos
59 1 esto es igual a punto 0 51 es 0.05
1 muy bien simplemente este esto de esto
de acá va entonces queremos determinar
un intervalo de confianza es decir
queremos dar un intervalo para el cual
sabes que déjame escribirlo así
queremos tener la confianza queremos
tener la confianza de que haya un 95 por
ciento de probabilidad un 95 por ciento
de que esta verdadera diferencia
recuerda tomamos esta diferencia que es
una diferencia de proporciones
muestrales pero hacer esa diferencia es
exactamente lo mismo que tomar una
muestra de la distribución muestral de
p1 p2 del estadístico entonces queremos
una probabilidad del 95% que la
verdadera diferencia o sea qué p1 p2
esté a puesta cierta distancia vamos a
ponerle esta a esta ave desde distancia
de de de qué cosa pues de la de esta
diferencia muestral que obtuvimos es
decir al bebé y lo voy a poner en así
0.05 1 para esto lo he escrito varias
veces y siempre lo escribo así sin dar
la fórmula porque pues aunque la fórmula
sea muy fácil de acordarse estoy aquí
nos da más la intuición de qué es lo que
estamos haciendo
queremos un 95 por ciento de
probabilidad de que esta diferencia la
verdad
la diferencia de proporciones que este
ave de 0.0 51 nuestra muestra que
obtuvimos verdad nuestra diferencia de
las muestras este enunciado que acabo de
escribir es exactamente lo mismo a que
haya un 95 por ciento de probabilidad 95
por ciento de probabilidad de que 0.05
uno esté a
pues otra vez de adedy y ahora la
diferencia de p1 p2 el verdadero
parámetro que es lo mismo que la media
de aquí entonces queremos encontrar una
cierta distancia voy a marcar la por acá
una distancia alrededor de esta media
nave para la cual si tomamos una muestra
una muestra de esta distribución por
ejemplo esta entonces la probabilidad de
que esa muestra quede en la región que
está desde distancia de la media sea
igual a 95 % y hacemos esto porque si la
muestra queda a la distancia de la media
entonces la media también queda de la
muestra con esto vamos a poder construir
nuestro intervalo tomando punto 0 51 de
y menos de ba entonces cómo lo hacemos
para hacer esto para calcular la
distancia de que sirve pues primero
tenemos que pasar a la distribución
normalizada a la que es la distribución
estándar voy a pasarme para acá arriba
para dibujarlo como detallito recordemos
que estamos usando la normal porque
tenemos una muestra bien grande y
probabilidad de cerca de la mitad
entonces la normal se aproxima bien
bueno con esto en mente ahora sí cómo le
hacemos para encontrar una región que
abarca el 90
por ciento de probabilidad en otras
palabras cuántas desviaciones estándar
necesitamos para que de acá a acá y
tenemos una distribución de dos colas de
acá acá nos queda el 95% del área bueno
antes de buscar cualquier información de
la tabla tenemos que recordar que la
tabla se está bien en las probabilidades
acumuladas entonces pensando que hay 2.5
por ciento por acá y también hay 2.5 por
ciento del lado izquierdo para encontrar
el valor crítico de z que nos interesa
debemos de considerar la probabilidad
acumulada hasta este punto que marcamos
entonces lo que realmente nos interesa
es buscar en la tabla no el 95 sino el
97.5 por ciento estamos buscando un
valor que contenga toda esta región de
aquí y estas regiones de 97.5 por ciento
si encontramos este valor de z de ambos
lados podemos cancelar el 2.5 y
obtenemos el 95 que queríamos bajar
entonces buscamos puntos 97 5 aquí está
y viene de 1.96 déjalo a punto por acá
nos queda 1.96 para esta distribución
que es la distribución normal
que tiene desviación estándar uno va a
1.96 regresando al problema la distancia
que nos interesa la distancia habíamos
dicho d es igual a 1.96 y ahora sí
multiplicado por la desviación estándar
de esta distribución
entonces nos quedaría 1.96 por esta
expresión por sigma pp 1 barra baja de p
1 barra menos p 2 barra y ahí está
entonces debemos calcular esta expresión
de acá multiplicarlo por 1.96 y
obtenemos la distancia que queremos pero
tenemos un problema no sabemos cuáles
son los verdaderos valores de p1 y p2
las medias poblacionales de hecho eso es
parte del problema queremos ver si
realmente hay una diferencia
significativa y sería fantástico
tenerlos pero podemos usar nuestras
muestras como ya vimos varias veces el
tener una muestra totota nos permite
estimar p1 y p2 a partir de las
proporciones muestrales que encontramos
eso está muy bueno entonces a lo mejor
no tengamos una igualdad exacta pero
podemos decir que la desviación estándar
es aproximadamente igual deja cambio
color nos va a quedar aproximadamente
igual y aquí vamos a poner las
proporciones muestrales puras barras va
esas de ahí si las conocemos aquí van
esas de ahí si las conocemos vamos a ver
cuánto nos da si lo metemos a la
calculadora y déjame sacar la
calculadora nos toca hacer una cuenta
todo está y es la siguiente ok
tenemos la raíz cuadrada de y nos queda
p 1 bar la proporción muestral de los
hombres que es puntos 64 2.642
y luego tenemos que multiplicar eso por
1 - aquí puse algo mal paréntesis por 1
- punto 642 aquí hay que cerrar el
paréntesis luego tenemos que dividir
entre 1000 verdad entonces dividido
entre mil a eso le tenemos que sumar la
segunda varianza muestral la de las
mujeres
entonces la proporción muestral es 0.25
91 hay que multiplicar multiplica china
aquí no puse por sports y luego hay que
multiplicar por 1 - punto 5 91 cerramos
el paréntesis es este término de acá sí
creo que otra vez puse mal aquí algo
paréntesis ese paréntesis dividido entre
y pues nada más tenemos que cerrar el
paréntesis que abrió la raíz verdad
entonces le voy a poner por aquí y
cierro el paréntesis le doy enter y nos
queda 0.02 17 vamos a ponerle punto 0 2
2 va entonces esta desviación estándar
es aproximadamente igual no nos escribió
es aproximadamente igual a 0.02 2 va
entonces regresando a la expresión de la
distancia que nos interesa este valor va
a ser aproximadamente igual
aproximadamente igual a cero punto 0 22
hagamos la multiplicación haberes 0.0 22
x 1.96 sacamos la calculadora y
multiplicamos por 1.96 enter y eso nos
queda aproximadamente 0.04 pues 3 vamos
a ponerle 0.04 3 entonces la distancia
de aquí es igual a es igual a cero
puntos 0 43
muy bien y ya con eso ya logramos
encontrar nuestro intervalo de confianza
bueno hay que hacer unas cuentas pero
hay 95 por ciento de probabilidad de que
p 1 - p 2 es decir la verdadera
diferencia de la proporción de este a
esta distancia a 0.04 3 de 0.0 51 la
diferencia de nuestras proporciones
muestrales vale muy bien entonces ya
nada más falta sumar y restar puntos 0
43 haciendo esto es 0.05 1 y a esto le
restamos punto 0 4 3 y nos da el en el
extremo izquierdo que es punto 0 08 y si
le sumamos punto 043 10.043 nos queda
punto 0 94 eso es el extremo derecho del
intervalo excelente con esto ya tenemos
el intervalo del 95% de confianza lo voy
a escribir por acá intervalo de
confianza del 95%
confianza del 95% vamos a ponerle
también que es para p1 p2 para p
1 - p 2 el intervalo es 0.008 y 0.09 4
déjame verificar si esto es lo que
obtuvimos de la calculadora entonces ya
terminamos al parecer o mejor dicho con
95% de confianza los hombres son más
propensos que las mujeres a votar por
ese candidato